Как перестать ходить по кругу и
перестать совершать одни и те же ошибки
это видео для тех кого не устраивает э
то как они живут в каких условиях они
живут Несмотря на то что они стремятся к
целям что-то делают но ничего в их жизни
не происходит и то что с ними происходит
их не устраивает Давайте разбираться с
этим и поговорим об этом обязательно
Ставьте лайк под этим видео и
внимательно слушайте дальше Итак для
того чтобы перестать ходить по кругу А я
вам сегодня дам три лайфхака что вам
нужно делать чтобы перестать ходить по
этому заколдованному кругу и чтобы
наконец-то вырваться из этой суеты
Первое что я лично в своей жизни очень
часто я бы сказал не часто а постоянно в
своей жизни применяю это не совершать
повторяемые ошибок или повторных ошибок
это правило вроде банальное но у вас у
всех наверняка возникает сразу же вопрос
Легко сказать а как это сделать так вот
я вам даю лайфхак как я это делаю когда
я соверше какую-либо ошибку Я
обязательно сразу же прописываю алгоритм
алгоритм - это как вот такой храповый
механизм Вы знаете такой механизм когда
Как трещётка так тык тык тык тык тык он
получается в эту сторону двигается А
назад не двигается так вот алгоритм -
это вот такой механизм который позволяет
вам не совершать одну и ту же ошибку
повторно поэтому Когда вы совершаете
какую-либо ошибку обязательно делайте
рефлексию То есть анализируйте почему
она произошла анализируйте и и сразу же
прописывается что вам нужно в следующий
раз делать чтобы эта ошибка не
повторилась приведу сразу же простой
пример Однажды на меня обиделся очень
близкий мне человек потому что когда я
выступал Я благодарил вокруг всех и
забыл упомянуть его Вы знаете я сам не
очень эмпатичный человек и со мной это
периодически случается и так как это
было по-моему второй или третий раз я
понял что это какой-то определённый
паттерн поэтому что я с делал я составил
себе алгоритм порядок благодарения то
есть кого я благодарю в первую очередь
во вторую очередь в третью В четвёртую в
пятую и так далее и каждый раз когда мне
предстоит А держать какую-то речь Вот
например
А я написал книгу и говорит вот
выступите понятно в такое выступление
подразумевает
благодарение других людей Всевышнего и
так далее я сразу же перед такой речью
Просто одним глазом смотрю на этот
алгоритм и у меня в голове картинка Я
знаю что говорить Как говорить В какой
последовательности и так далее И этот
алгоритм спас и спасает меня во многих
случаях и таких алгоритмов У меня на
самом деле очень много и На многие
случаи жизни и вообще я считаю так
алгоритмы они сами по себе ресурс это
сам по себе ресурс который Вас оберегает
от ошибок от повторных ошибок и я часто
говорю
что бизнесмены должны быть как гусеница
которая вот так ползёт вперёд пожирает
события и ошибки А из задницы Извиняюсь
за выражение вместо паутинки у него
вылезают алгоритмы и эти алгоритмы в
виде паутинки не позволяют этой гусеницы
потом упасть вы бы должны представить
что что вы
пожирает которые с вами происходят и вы
пожирает ошибки как последствия своих
каких-то неправильных действий Вы должны
это пожирать и выдавать алгоритмы и
благодаря этим
алгоритмам вы не будете совершать
повторных ошибок и это сильно ускорит
ваше движение вперёд к вашей цели
переходим ко второму лайфхак для того
чтобы не крутиться как белка в колесе
вам нужно не делать одних и тех же
действий ожидая при этом разный
результат
ещё поему этен это говорил Безумие это
когда человек совершает одни и теже
действия ожидает разный результат так
вот к сожалению большинство людей по
сути из-за того что их мозг или внимание
полностью захвачено социальными сетями и
они живут неосознанной жизнью то по сути
они живут как Безумцы они совершают одни
и те же действия каждый день ходят на
одну и ту же работу одними и теми же
путями делают эту работу так же как
вчера не привносить ничего нового
общаются с одними и теми же людьми
дорогие мои Откуда в вашей жизни тогда
будет изме мне почему вы тогда считаете
что вы достойны того чтобы жить другой
жизнью Хорошо по-моему Сказала како
Шанель которая сказала Если вы хотите
жить
как другие не могут Вы должны делать то
что другие не хотят и это относится как
раз к этому второму правилу Поэтому если
вы хотите чтобы в вашей жизни случилось
что-то хорошее другое Перестаньте делать
одни и те же действия либо начните
делать что-то другое либо делайте то же
самое но по
и вы увидите что Результаты будут другие
третий лайфхак для того чтобы выйти из
замкнутого Круга из этого беличева
колеса в котором которая нас всех
засасывает нужно иметь чёткую цель и
измеримые метрики прогресса движение к
ней То есть у вас должна быть цель и
измеримые метрики которые показывает вы
движетесь приближаетесь к своей цели или
не приближайтесь потому что проблема
большинства людей в том что у них есть
цель но нету метрики
показывающие насколько они приближаются
к своей цели в результате по сути их
цель является не целью их цель является
просто мечтой а мечта она на то и мечта
что она никогда не осуществляется пока
она не перерождается в цель поэтому
третий лайфхак Если вы хотите вырваться
из этого порочного Круга ежедневной
суеты превращайте свои мечты в цели с
конкретными
метриками показывающими Прогресс
продвижения к ней Если вы примените в
своей жизни хотя бы три этих лайфхака я
уверен вы покинете эту суету и беличье
колесо и в вашей жизни начнут
происходить чудесные изменения очень
часто бывает такая ситуация что многие
люди утверждают что они что-то хотят и
что у них есть какие-то цели и они целый
день Работают но ничего не происходит
здесь я дам вам такой бонусный
дополнительный лайфхак для этого ребята
ежедневно рефлексию звучит сложно но что
такое рефлексия вы просто берте 15 минут
10 минут в конце дня и спрашиваете
задаёте себе только один вопрос что я
сегодня
сделал какое действие которое приближает
меня к моей цели просто Задайте себе
этот вопрос и утром Когда вы идёте на
работу или когда просыпаетесь Задайте
себе вопрос что я сегодня сделаю которая
хотя бы на шаг приблизит меня к моей
цели Если вы будете задавать ежедневно
два этих вопроса вы поймёте
Действительно ли вы хотите идти к своей
цели или эта цель вас не драйви если эта
цель вас не дравит не зажигает не
мотивирует будьте уверены эта цель
навязана вам Извне Значит эта цель Не
ваша а для того чтобы понять какая цель
ваша для этого нужно вам побыть в
одиночестве и знать определённые
алгоритмы Ну которыми я часто делюсь в
своём Telegram канале переходите по
ссылке которые я оставляю здесь внизу и
у меня к вам большая просьба Напишите в
комментариях ваши случаи когда вы
крутились как белка в колесе и не могли
и найти выход из этого Круга и благодаря
чему вам удалось из него вылезти либо
если вы до сих пор находитесь с такой
ситуации Напишите после этого видео
пришло ли у вас понимание как вырваться
из этого Круга и что вы будете для этого
делать бывают люди которые всё время за
чем-то гоняются за новыми знания
занимаются
саморазвитием суетятся хотя у них в
жизни всё благополучно и нормально Вы
знаете почему это происходит это синдром
называется это Fear Of missing Out с
английского переводится как страх
упустить что-то обычно это страх
психологически вызывается социальными
сетями Где нам всем демонстрируется
успешный успех и такое Складывается
ощущение что все развиваются все куда-то
идут у всех что-то что-то получается Вот
только я отстаю от жизни на самом деле
это часто происходит потому что человек
а мало синхронизируется с собой и идёт
на поводу у социальных сетей блогеров и
так далее рекомендую такому человеку
побольше быть самим собой и чаще
разговаривать со своим внутренним
мечтателем со своим сердцем со всевышним
и думать о том как о нём думают люди и
как они его воспринимают Поэтому в таких
случаях больше побудьте оставайтесь в
одиночестве и думайте над своей жизнью я
уверен вы
приблизительную и удовлетворению тем что
у вас есть